sono belle
si è da quando sono piccolo che sono
balbuziente ma tranquilli oggi andrà
bene non era un caso grave anche se a
scuola e bambini possono essere molto
cattive fanno bene i comunisti a
mangiarli
voi direte assurdo la cosa veramente
assurda è che io riesca a parlare
fluentemente in pubblico in un evento
importante come questo pensate che alle
scuole medie era già strano che io
dicessi fluentemente in modo fluente con
l'adolescenza ha escogitato degli
escamotage linguistici per risolvere i
blocchi che si venivano a creare mentre
parlavo ho sviluppato tutta una serie di
sinonimi un bagaglio di parole
equivalente un libro di vocaboli che mi
permettevano di volta in volta di
superare il blocco che si veniva a
creare mentre parlavo chiaramente questa
non era la soluzione perché il problema
rimaneva con il tempo tutto si è
attenuato sempre in pratica risolto
soprattutto grazie alla terapia se alla
terapia andate in terapia brutti matti
folli dementi frustrati forsennati fuori
di testa perché riserve si vede ma
tranquilli perché il vostro difetto il
vostro blocco potrebbe essere il vostro
punto di forza potrebbe essere la vostra
arma segreta le debolezze grazie alle
idee possono diventare la vostra forza
poteva essere un difetto invalidante
poteva essere un problema irrisolvibile
in realtà questa debolezza mi ha
permesso di immagazzinare tutta una
serie di parole che io oggi uso nel mio
lavoro faccio il pubblicitario
in pratica grazie a queste parole riesco
ad ottenere un lavoro soddisfacente
in realtà lavoro nei social media sono
un pubblicitario ma non come quelli di
una volta che sceglievano la foto più
bella
scrivevano la frase giusta al posto
giusto
andavano a incollare il cartellone o
stampavano la pagina pubblicitaria e
lavoro finiva lì le persone dovevano
solo guardare il cartellone subivano
passivamente non potevano rispondere
oggi nei social media le persone
rispondono commentano condividono
recensiscono insultano il più delle
volte passano oltre ignorano chiaramente
perché nelle nostre bacheche abbiamo un
affollamento di messaggi di post di
video di meme di foto del battesimo
della nipote tizia assunta insomma di
spam
che poi in italiano significa immondizia
il romano monnezza quindi a roma abbiamo
la monnezza online e offline
siamo fortunati quindi come riusciamo ad
emergere come possono le aziende colpire
come riescono a rendere interessanti i
loro messaggi quando si trovano tra
gattini pucciosi e le foto di diletta
leotta devono diventare delle persone
devono diventare delle persone devono
esprimere i propri valori e i propri
sentimenti devono esprimere le proprie
opinioni e non devono avere paura di
farlo devono insomma avere un carattere
sui social possono essere simpatici
scanzonati sexy comici eleganti o cinici
ma devono dimostrarlo devono far vedere
i propri pregi
e i propri difetti le proprie debolezze
perché sono quelle che ci
contraddistinguono con tappo
siamo partiti proprio da qui taffo è
un'agenzia funebre una delle più
conosciute in italia siamo partiti
pensando che fosse anacronistico dire
esami più bravi a seppellire le salme
quindi ho pensato di farli conoscere
prima per quello che sono e cioè persone
e poi per quello che vendono e cioè
funerali i necrofori o come diciamo qui
a frascati ma anche in italia becchini
beccamorti o in francese casa mortari
sono sempre stati visti di cattivo
occhio portatori di sciagure o
semplicemente di sfiga abbiamo ribaltato
il concetto di morte perché la loro
debolezza in realtà era la loro forza
perché sono una agenzia con le pale
danno consigli anche medici non
vaccinatevi siamo pronti anche ad
un'epidemia come le persone fanno le
feste comandate e quindi a natale puoi
ma non esagerare
dopo natale viene capodanno quindi buona
fine
ma senza buon inizio perché arriva la
befana che tutte le feste porta via
no non è l'epifania
[Applauso]
la befana si sa ma ridotta instabile
come i nostri governi quindi andremo ad
elezioni presto forse quindi italiani vi
aspettiamo alle urne dalle fredde lapidi
di tappo sì basta
si passa alle piastre ardenti di
roadhouse nei loro ristoranti hanno
tagli di carne pregiata e grigliate
miste ma dicono che la carne faccia male
questa è una debolezza come combattiamo
i nasi vegani li seduciamo con i piaceri
della carne perché scegliamo solo manzi
selezionate
se poi non avete tanta fame non
preoccupatevi perché le loro salsicce
più sono piccole che sono buone
a volte le dimensioni non contano poi in
realtà c'è che un po di fame l'avrebbe
ma non ha molto cibo a disposizione
medici senza frontiere aiuta uomini
donne e bambini colpiti da guerre
epidemie e catastrofi
anche qui abbiamo cambiato il punto di
vista invece che far vedere la
sofferenza di queste popolazioni
abbiamo fatto vedere i piccoli problemi
quotidiani di tutti i giorni però i
nostri facendo un parallelismo perché
ognuno ha le sue guerre
aiutaci a combattere le nostre e quindi
le file alle poste contro la fila per i
vaccini vestiti da stirare contro
vestiti da trovare il traffico stradale
contro il fango paludoso ferragosto al
mare contro una grande siccità ognuna
delle guerre aiutaci a combattere le
nostre chiaramente le guerre e i
problemi non sono solo in africa ma
anche qui in italia
al sud italia soprattutto
cioè fondazione con il sud che una
fondazione che attraverso bandi e
attività aiuta il mezzogiorno ma sono
problemi o stereotipi ai meridionali non
va di lavorare
questa è una gran cazzata c'è povertà al
sud c'è crisi non abbiamo diamanti ma
l'acqua cristallina mafia a tutti i
mafiosi
la criminalità organizzata ma noi lo
siamo di più insomma ragionando sempre
al contrario scegliendo sempre la via
più pericolosa facendo scelte assurde
diverse sono riuscite a creare uno stile
di comunicazione nuovo che abbatte i
tabù prende in giro gli stereotipi ma
difende valori e persone una
comunicazione nuova che non mente
sicuramente vuole vendere qualcosa ma
non prende in giro nessuno
io credo che davvero dalle debolezze
nascano poi delle idee che diventano la
nostra forza superando le paure
riusciamo ad essere più consapevoli e
quindi capaci di trovare quelle idee che
ci portano a fare delle cose
sensazionali per gli altri mentre per
noi che le facciamo sono normali tranne
questa che ho fatto oggi grazie